[Man]: Give me an advice as a parent
[Gary]: I can tell you, yea.
I can tell you what not to do
[Reporter]: As the the US college admission bribery allegations continue
to expand, they include high profile celebries
and wealthy families.
[Gary]: Going to Harvard or Stanford or Yale
is a badge that people walk around proudly
and they're fu*king their kids up.
I love how everybody's focused on how these parents f*ck other kids
that couldn't get in
[Man]: There are a lot of advantages
for rich people
to make it an uneven playing field
[Journalist]: Kids who belive that they're boxed out because of social standing
[Man]: Oportunity 101
[Gary]: No, no. They totally f*ck their own children in perpetuity
you have a kid who knows they're not good enough and that mommy and daddy buy their way in. that is broken forever
for sure
your parents don't believe in you
These parents actually care more about other people's opinions
about their kids more than they do with the mental well being
of their own children
I f a parents thinks that a kid's acomplishment is a reflection of them
now you have a disconnect, now you're not a parent and a child
you're a person with a product
The way we do school today and the way we structure our kids for success
is so broken worldwide
It doesn't matter what you want for your kids
the only thing you should want for your kids is happiness
and the best way for somebody to be happy si for them to be self aware
your job is to reverse engineer them
at all times
your job is to watch them
what their intrests are, what their desires are, what their talents are
and communicate to them on their level
not on your expectations or ambitions
lean into the things that make them happy
[rewind]
[Man]: Give me an advice as a parent
[Gary]: I can tell you what not to do
you shouldn't buy
you shouldn't buy your kid's way into fancy colleges